hello reject nation it's Greg al-baqir
and I'm it's a Mesa don't understand the
reference but I'm assuming it's definite
related right this trailer came out a
few days ago but I said in a video how
to wait when Anita is all healed from
surgery on her back ankle you can
speculate what am i right but right [ __ ]
on back away I'm wearing this lovely you
definitely know where'd you get that you
gave it to me for my birthday I did yes
you did thank you giving yeah we accept
well because you know that I love dozen
them so much that's why you waited oh
that's right just all makes sense now
okay well you guys like enough already
yeah yes it is true yeah let's get such
a dog talking quit procrastinating why
are you even why are you here like why
are you quitting on the trailers for LA
the trailer I don't even want to watch
your reaction really I know I just want
to see this trailer
I'd rather just watch the original keep
it going
it's merciful make life miserable egg
like dangerous
[Music]
run chases written insta-death god yeah
what exactly can you do with this death
know what can they see what happens on a
few crime
consult all crime you think I'm crazy
these are not crazy enough we can change
the world I like that taking credit for
over 4 min to death
Wow all those who don't know how to
close its victims you know you know
scope of limited for the curve like
you're ready for the one that goes in
the Sun I just make sure you can
[Music]
I promise you you naughty boy
[Music]
Wow okay what is it gone okay look look
before you get happier than a bunch here
such in a bunch though as a guy who is
not familiar at all with what Death Note
is I'm kicked out of the way I should
give my two second opinion really quick
first this way you say something worked
wild pose yeah I think it looks really
cool it does look cool I like the grungy
vibe everything visual listicle II looks
beautiful in a haunting horror and I
kind of have this teen horror element to
it without feeling like a teen movie
about it it feels that much more than
just high school kids kind of you know I
see a lot of trailers for movies of high
school kids and like horror scenarios
and they look so awful
is this a filmer show actually I think
it's going to be a film Netflix fell
yeah it feels like a film which is first
I would rather have them do a show
because I feel like Death Note is so
involved yes like this yeah to like try
to condense Death Note into a film is
going to be very difficult which is why
I'm going to be more lenient about my
criticism Willem Dafoe as I don't know
what was it really are you kissing me
yes okay yeah he sounds off amazing he's
like perfect for you you know no idea
but it's absolutely perfect for you
that's good to know because his voice
work there was awesome just to clarify
he it's his Death Note and I love the
concept of what the Death Note is that's
really neat to write down anyone's name
I can think of a ton of youtubers okay
new star I room
Oh under me yeah rather and then all of
Collider videos Oh lizard again I know
I've lost you in that movie trivia
Shruti okay I guess that's it I mean I
normally do better at these but no
special back and forth so actually yeah
what do you actually find that
fascinating to see your point of view
not knowing anything about death no and
I'm like okay I can see that so it isn't
restricting basically with Death Note
there's the Shinigami named Ryu and he's
bored he's a god of death whatever and
he throws down this Death Note randomly
so Death Note that he's supposed to use
to to do the deaths and stuff he throws
it down randomly to just whoever is
there or as this upstanding Japanese
student who's like goody two-shoes under
the radar kid finds it and the bullet
what to him who is light I guess
Turner in this show but it's light
yagami and okay so they change huh yeah
the whole thing is supposed to be about
like the struggles that he goes through
and then Howard killed Howard to kill
anyone and then turning into the or
turning that into like a god complex
thinking like this was meant to be for
me and this and you see the struggles of
this goody-two-shoes student just
totally turned into someone else cool
that didn't seem to be what we're
happening here is I thought it was going
down that exact path you were talking
about but he didn't look like a
goody-two-shoes student to me he looks
like a grungy kid from yeah well that
doesn't look like you who looks like
he's gonna evolve into it here oh yeah
which mean I don't know if I saw that I
could see your point of view how that
looked like it to me it looked more like
and this is something I think that Death
Note fans al have a problem with Misa
the character the girl I don't know her
name in this but the girl that looked
like mises character seemed to be
influencing light and in the TV show or
sorry the anime light was the one that
was influencing her and in this they're
making it look like there's a love story
between them and they're bonding over
this Death Note
whereas in the anime she had her own
separate Death Note and they were
very independent of each other a first
man he manipulated her and used her and
just like kinda for his own gain so the
main character is not the in the anime
is not the most good of people no he
doesn't end up being I mean at first are
you sure yeah he was conflicted he was
trying to do right it was like social
justice warrior type and then the animal
himself is doing yen and it just
spiraled into this like just evil who's
the guy in the hoodie the guy in the
hoodie is el la Liat and what's his
curious character is actually completely
different obviously it was like this
Goffe pasty looking kid like super
awkward super weird in the show and you
love him for it but this guy seemed to
like have it a little more together I
know that a Latif's anvil is that his
name I think it's look you Stansfield
he's a very attractive guy and el is not
supposed to be like a super attractive
guys like this like sunk and I like
weird dirty Japanese dude or like
British or something cuz he was like
went to school in England you're not
supposed to be like oh this beautiful
man is gonna take down light you know
but I feel like maybe that's why they're
masking what are not will masking and
wiki-scan filled because they don't want
to show how beautiful it super
good-looking guy I mean the trailer I
feel like if I watched it again I'd be
less confused I was kind of yeah as it
seemed like life is a kinky organic to
my life was getting that had the Death
Note was going on it's really dark path
high body count that was all really
appealing to me I love watching people
just succumb to Dorian and I really love
doing that if that's where they go with
it and then it looked like this other
guy who they didn't make so clear hell
yeah he's a good guy he's like the
detective he's like Sherlock Holmes
basically but in the perspective of the
audience's he could perceive to have the
antagonist for our main character yes
okay cuz yeah it was making him look
like he was a villain okay not a villain
but you to our main character he's being
a antagonist yeah he's not the villain
he's my hero
I love LM Emma here amazed like
technically thank you exactly the good
guy but he anyone I can ASSU our life
here
yeah he wants to stop like doesn't like
know who he is the trend isn't make it
look like lightning I don't think I mean
he does in the show eventually they do
meet and there's a whole like sabacc
ulation where else thinks like okay I
think that he's Kira which is funny that
they have Kira in this because I saw the
candles and Kira was spelled out the
reason he was even called Kira in the
Japanese version and this is so drew
what sounds weird is because Japanese
people can't see Killick oh that's where
Kira comes from and and it's funny that
they use that in the American version
because in Lincoln doesn't even make
sense but okay that's cool they want to
bring the element of his name still
being here
this trailers making it look like they
didn't know who the guy in the hoodie
was and now I mean in the anime they
definitely meet they have a back and
forth and then L is like really trying
to figure out a piece like Kira or not
and he doesn't know if he should just
put his name down is that the problem
well like thinks in the enemy I don't
know what's gonna happen here that if he
put his name in the book it's going to
be obvious that he's the killer so it's
like that flowery don't ya you're not
trying to do it in the fashion okay that
obvious but also in the trailer I
noticed like there was a lot of mayhem
and a lot of death in very different
ways whereas in the anime like you knew
the Kira deaths because he always did it
the same they were always a heart attack
you'd write the name in the book and the
person would have a heart attack so they
link to that all to cure it I don't know
how they're going to link all these
deaths to cure a lot of death scene is a
final destination like right and which
is how do we know if that's cure if it's
just whatever I mean so how are you I'm
interested to show how they link it in
the anime they would have a heart attack
here that was like death works in its
own funny ways like yeah that's the
nation yeah yeah yeah like I saw that
scene wasn't there ladder coming yeah
yeah like a top of a van or something
yeah I think they're changing it to
expand to a different audience to be
honest with you yes I mean obviously it
looked like they were doing a love story
scenario between Misa and light or
whoever her name is in light well all
the changes you run up to me sound very
American they are an advance in Seattle
so it is going to be it should be aren't
you
I mean I think if you're going to base
it in America then you should bring that
American element into it that's another
thing with light like he looks like he's
not like that honor student upstanding
good guy with good morale with his dad
being a detective and stuff and like
that's very respectable in Japan you
know we like you look at that character
and you're like he would never do
anything wrong you know but then he him
do all this bad stuff in that anime it
makes you question your own convictions
like would I do that
I know anime is very visual so how does
this visually line up with what you know
death no um it looked very Seattle okay
it looks very Seattle I think they
should stay true to that because it does
it does have that element of grunge and
like death and like chaos and I think at
school I don't know gloomy weather
gloomy weather yes the Seattle weather
not like that in the anime but Ryu
'click rad so I mean those little
shadowy figures knew yeah we're shots of
him in the anime yeah that's guy no he's
a huge like part of Lights world and
you've heard it all the time what I'm a
little disappointed in and there was a
little clip where it looked like they
were like light and the character that
supposed to believe me so were like
looking into this to the death no
probably and like kind of intimate which
kind of makes me sad because it means
like maybe they're sharing the does know
maybe they're doing this together which
in the anime I'm going to miss rim rim
was an awesome Shinigami
like everything Tommy has a definite yes
every Shinigami has a definite REM was
such an awesome character and brought
such an interesting dynamic into this I
feel like they're going to totally
matter yeah yeah I'd really like Jerome
and she cared over Misa and like just
was just there for her and it looks like
in this they're just sharing the dust
net so Mesa is not even going to have
her own death note she's not going to be
independent of anything the socks man
but I get it I get it I can see that
they're trying to bring them together
with the Death Note create that love
sorry for those people that are not
movie they're going to make it more
yummy yeah absolutely they're bringing
in that audience I get it it's like so
you just have to like look at this as a
separate entity than the anime it's a
totally different thing it could be like
an ode to be given a mayor you know
yeah and I heard that the people that
were directing it or writing or whatever
were fans of Death Note
so I feel like they will probably bring
some justice to it in our event but I
feel a lot of Directors say that Netflix
is also do happen I have faith in
Netflix I do have faith in them I'm
going to look at this like it's own
entity I'm not going to try and compare
and contrast too much I love Death Note
for winners
I love the live action Japanese versions
of Death Note I feel complete and having
those I hadn't read the manga I'd love
to do that I'm sure I'd love that too
but I'm gonna see this and if I love it
I love it if I don't I don't I still
have my anime I go watch that it's a
great attitude to have yeah doesn't seem
like a lot of people I guess that I feel
their pain but my childhood I can watch
the anime and just pretend this movie
never existed that's all you got to do
the reason I said why it looks like he
might go down a Shiro like pastures is
they have this moment in the trailer
from what the trailer was giving me it
looks like the complex with L who seems
kind of public I was this part not even
normally not in the animes not public
but yeah there's a part words like
speaking to a crowd yeah he doesn't care
at all he's more like an agoraphobic it
seemed like like character was
conflicted about what he's been doing
and is even like we're not the good guys
anymore like realizing yeah he's done I
don't know if the hero's the right word
but somehow life comes into the light
more towards art or maybe he's saying
that like people are not viewing us as
the good guy anymore
so people were worshiping him with the
candle all that of a sudden it takes a
turn and people are like no MELAS Ella's
bringing a new yes okay answer so it
couldn't be that - like well I'd like it
if they mate I mean american-style would
probably miss him but I'm guessing
America he wants out I would love it if
they kept in pure sociopath yeah yeah I
don't know in this he seems like he's
not associate that it seems like he
actually cares he has empathy you know
like yeah but in the anime was super
socio yeah big time it would be nice to
have him as that there's some of it in
my America you know Americans need a
sensitive type of hero
anti-hero you call that if I save the
cat worth you know they can't care who
might not have the most redeeming
qualities has just one or two to make
you laugh gone through yeah oh yeah I
think that we we need that we need that
care we need that we need that indicator
don't get it in our president we now did
it in a movie well Anita thank you for
being here you have made the weight
worth while because I would have seen
this and talked for a minute
and what had not so much more to say I
what I wouldn't have anything important
to say maybe thank you maybe do another
video on done like your challenge now or
about it if you want again I'll just
stick to this because you know you
waited for me and I appreciate that this
is our video much love to you and on
today's rain to you subscribe to the
really know you did you have a beer
subscribe to the real reject click that
notification bail check out our perks
and rewards on patreon but most
importantly go to the Anita stargazer
channel check out her at content what am
i coming back on whenever you want us to
happen for you I got that surgery
beautify us be better I look died Greg I
know scary man I was almost relieved oh
you're like thank God thank God so be
John didn't have to shoot her after all
I'm dang it gotta get myself a death
note means I'm with a guy honking his
horn during Irene I got a definite I'm
used to everything people say horse [ __ ]
I've never tried it I just actually like
try on some I don't care about ah dude
that's how it started playing like hi
I'm Greg what's your name no bill write
down bit what's your last name s Preston
Dilla's Preston okay that's square i
squired
i actually know how you good